[Musique]
béatrice piron bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue pour ce café politique ici à
montigny-le-bretonneux vous êtes député
des yvelines de la 3e circonscription
depuis le 18 juin à dernier c'est votre
premier mandat
tout à fait avant la campagne même des
législatives vous n'avez donc jamais été
élu pourquoi à 50 ans passés décidé de
vous engager de cette manière je m'étais
engagé dans d'autres causes devant
d'autres organisations j'ai été
président d'une association parents
d'élèves par exemple à une époque j'ai
été chef d'entreprise c'était une façon
pour moi de m'engager aussi
avec d'autres personnes dans ma région
et l'ag il ya eu début de campagne
présidentielle je fais pas partie des
premiers premiers marcheurs et c'est en
fin de compte en vivant ce début de
campagne présidentielle que j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à emmanuel
macron et que j'ai dit mais j'ai envie
de faire partie de ces gens qui vont
transformer la france
je ne me suis jamais intéressé politique
justement parce que ça avait pour moi
des connotations très très négatif
jusqu'à présent et je me suis dit et si
enfin on peut faire la politique
autrement
je fais partie de ces gens qui
n'aimaient pas la politique précédente
et qui voudrait faire partie de cette
nouvelle politique et à construire avec
quand vous vous êtes lancé ce n'était
pas forcément dans l'objectif d'être
candidate ensuite sur l'élection
législative
absolument pas non non absolument pas
donc il ya vraiment eu un appel manuel
mac ronde au niveau de la société civile
au niveau des femmes où il voulait
justement des nouveaux profils et je me
suis dit pourquoi pas moi ça correspond
à mon profil donc j'ai candidaté pour
les législatives mais c'était pas mon
objectif il ya un an vous m'auriez dit
vous allez être député je redis non
faites erreur parce que c'était pas dans
mes objectifs
une cette vague république en marche aux
élections législatives qui en général
suis toujours là lection présidentielle
il ya toujours un mouvement pour le pour
le parti qui a été élu à la présidence
donc vous en avez bénéficié vous
récupérez la la députation dans cette
circonscription des yvelines
on vous reproche néanmoins ce manque
d'expérience politique parce que c'est
un handicap pour vous écouter les gens
jugeront dans trois ans dans cinq ans
aujourd'hui je suis pas la seule à ne
pas avoir d'expérience et une grande
majorité des gens et les gens ont choisi
de positionner des gens qui n'avaient
pas l'expérience
donc ils ne peuvent pas à la fois
reprocher et choisir donc c'est les
français qui ont choisi de positionner
des gens qui n'avaient pas d'expérience
en politique justement pour transformer
les choses dont ils jugent auront dans
quelques années vous avez évoqué ce
rapport que vous saviez à la politique
n'étiez pas très convaincu par la
politique il ya aucun homme aucune femme
politique personnalités politiques qui
auparavant
vous appuyez vous séduire les blessés
dans la politique j'avais voté presque
gênante en citoyenne vous votiez voilà
je voter régulièrement à toutes les
élections je n'ai jamais fait partie des
gens qui s'abstenait mai
et je voudrais plutôt pour des idées
plutôt que pour des hommes je voudrais
plutôt pour des projets donc je suis une
personne qui a la chance opportunité de
faire une partie de mes études à
l'étranger de partir professionnels
blanc étranger et je suis très attaché à
cette ouverture vers l'étranger et donc
j'avais quand même des bonnes bases sur
tout ce qui était euros et justement ce
qui m'a fait peur un moment dans toutes
les autres campagnes politiques c'était
une impression que la france essayait de
se refermer sur elle-même de refermer
ses frontières donc je compatis
combattent et c'est cette idéologie de
se refermer sur soi même donc voilà mais
effectivement je n'ai je n'avais pas de
d'hommes clés ou de modèle à suivre
ni gauche ni droite c'est le leitmotiv
fossiles de la république en marche
on dit aussi à la fois de gauche à
droite à la fois gauche est à la fois
droite même si on entend dans l'opinion
publique
c'est un petit peu plus à droite qu'à
gauche est ce que vous partagez
non non non je ne pense pas je crois que
les gens ou les journalistes ont mis
beaucoup de focus sur des petits bouts
de loi qui ont été évoqués et maître
malheureusement - il faut plus sur
d'autres qui arrivent aussi actuellement
quand on parle
d'augmenter la feuille de paye le
salaire net des gens personne fait de la
publicité là dessus aujourd'hui pourtant
ça fait partie du projet de loi de
finances 2010 8 ce qui devrait être
perceptible dès le mois de janvier sur
les feuilles de salaire voilà donc les
gens vont voir des améliorations sur
leur feuille de salaire au mois de
janvier au mois d'octobre donc
évidemment le mans ne s'est pas fait en
un jour donc il y a un timing est
quelque chose qui va être fait petit à
petit mais mais mais ce timing si on
peut dire de dire que même s'il ya des
améliorations pour les français par
exemple la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation à partir de l'automne
prochain puisque la majorité des
personnes
un grand nombre des personnes voient la
taxe d'habitation sera un impôt payé
soit mensuellement soit au mois
d'octobre ce sont des améliorations qui
arrive en 2018 donc aujourd'hui les
marcheurs se mobilisent ils vont nous
aider également à faire passer ce
message pour communiquer sur le gain de
pouvoir d'achat pour tous les français
on quitte la partie peut-être politique
pendant quelques instants peut-être pour
parler du territoire aussi parce que
vous parlez de votre découverte delà de
la politique en tant que député à
présent mais le territoire des yvelines
vous le connaissez bien ça fait 20 ans
oui ça fait ça fait plus de vingt ans
maintenant que j'habite dans les
yvelines
donc j'ai longtemps habité autour de
saint cyr l'école fondée florissant sur
l'école et j'ai déménagé il ya plus de
dix ans donc
à ton avis vous savez un attachement
particulier département yvelinois nom
original origines je suis de province
mais je suis venu pour travailler voilà
quand je me suis installé dans 78 un
petit peu par hasard parce qu'on
entreprises et et attrapes à ce moment
là parce que vous avez voyagé un petit
peu oui vous avez séjourné à tokyo
pendant suis parti je suis parti dix
minutes trois ans pour aller à tokyo
puis je suis revenue
donc ça veut dire aujourd'hui que c'est
aussi la philosophie vous appliquez
cette ouverture vous parler de l'europe
vous parler avec votre parcours y aussi
l'international via l'international ya
le fait que j'ai changé de métier
plusieurs fois donc ma première activité
professionnelle c'était dans une banque
puis j'ai arrêté je suis parti faire de
l'informatique j'ai fait pendant 20 ans
de l'informatique puis j'ai arrêté je me
crée une entreprise maintien à domicile
donc dans le sanitaire et social et puis
j'ai arrêté et
et là je pars en politique donc je pense
pas que je sois quelqu'un d'instable
parce que j'ai quand même passé vingt
ans à l'aréna même entreprise mais je
pense que dans une carrière qui
aujourd'hui pour la plupart d'entre nous
dirons plus de 40 ans on peut
s'intéresser à plusieurs domaines
donc ça veut dire que le message aussi à
faire passer c'est qu'il ya plusieurs
vies professionnelles en tout la cger du
professionnel voilà moi j'ai fait
plusieurs formations aussi dans ma vie
j'avais une formation d'ingénieur après
j'ai fait un billet pour m'approcher
plus de la finance et la gestion donc
donc on doit se former tout au long de
sa vie on doit évoluer et en politique
aujourd'hui pour vous la politique vous
la voyez comment c'est un une parenthèse
avec la vie professionnelle c'est une
nouvelle expérience aussi
professionnelle la politique c'est un
nouveau métier
alors disons que si certains utilisent
comme un métier pour moi ça sera
sûrement de courte durée puisque
j'approche la même de la fin de ma vie
professionnelle
certains ont commencé donc en marche
beaucoup plus jeune et commence donc une
vie professionnelle ou un métier dans la
politique aux alentours de 20 ans moi
moi j'ai plus de 50 ans je suis grand
mère donc c'est vraiment la fin de mon
activité
peut-être que je ne ferais que cinq ans
ça sera 5 ans de découverte et
d'apprentissage et d'apports justement
de mon expérience professionnelle donc
c'est très intéressant pour moi
peut-être que ça sera 10e ne sais pas
mais c'est quelque chose encore très
passionnant aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression presque de retourner nos
sur certains sujets à la fac d'apprendre
de découvrir
mais à côté de ça je suis incapable
aujourd'hui d'apporter mon expérience de
chef d'entreprise mon vécu du problème
d'emploi si la politique s'arrête
justement vous savez déjà ce que vous
allez faire vous allez retourner à une
vie professionnelle je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas il me manquera peut-être deux
ou trois ans avant ma retraite je pense
j'avais envie là s'il n'avait pas été
élu par exemple de faire un petit peu
d'enseignements
professionnels et d'enseignants et alors
est ce que l'engagement politique
pourrait aussi se prendre d'autres
d'autres formes vous resteriez tout de
même malgré tout au sein de la
république en marche pour pour militer
être active ou est-ce que là c'est
vraiment une parenthèse j'ai du mal à me
projeter aussi loin gérer comment
aujourd'hui je suis quelqu'un qui
m'adapte et je m'adapte dont
classification donc là j'ai découvert il
ya un an l'emploi public en marche avec
des idées qui étaient très novatrice est
très intéressante
qu'est ce que ça sera dans cinq ans
aujourd'hui personne n'est capable de le
dire je crois que personne n'était
capable de dire qu'on serait aujourd'hui
au pouvoir il ya un an
dans cinq ans ça paraît tellement loin
que peut-être que oui je poursuivrai
peut-être que non je ne sais pas vous
disais retourner un petit peu sur les
bancs de la faculté pour apprendre un
petit peu est bon à prendre aussi vous
allez vous en contact vous allez à la
rencontre pardon des gens d administrer
des différentes vous avez une permanence
itinérante et de génie d'un vin se fixe
plus itinérant pour être au plus chaque
chambre des communes de la
circonscription on va clairement être
pas mais en tout cas la volonté c'était
c'était d'aller dans chacune des
communes au plus près du citoyen pour
moi aussi peut-être les intéresser à la
politique parce que vous même vous
l'avais dit au début vous n'étiez pas
intéressé par la politique donc là c'est
d'aller les rencontrer voilà je crois
qu'il faut être proche des gens et c'est
un engagement que j'avais pris pendant
ma campagne pendant mes réunions
publiques comme quoi je ferai une
permanences itinérantes
quand je vais proposer donc à
à la municipalité du ciné
monsieur le maire de séné a assumé que
ça s'était jamais fait qu'il n'en voyait
pas l'utilité que il trouvait pas ça
utile qui pensaient que toutes les
personnes de sackville était à même de
se déplacer ailleurs et de venir vous
rencontrer avait dit que c'était pas si
loin alors c'est vrai que c'est pas si
loin
mais bon on verra dans la pratique pour
mieux commencer ses vécus et les
rapports avec les différents élus et
peut-être notamment le maire du chesnay
parce que lui était candidat face à vous
il n'a pas voilà la défaite a été
difficile pour philippe brillault
aujourd'hui vous avez des échanges parce
que vous tournez député c'est important
aussi d'échanger avec les élus nous nous
sommes rencontrés à plusieurs reprises
il m'a reçu dans sa mairie nous avons
des relations tout à fait courtoise est
tout à fait normal sur vos différents
engagements au sein de l'assemblée vous
êtes notamment aux membres du groupe de
travail sur les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de paris oui alors là là
au départ donc on sait on ce tous
inscrits on est très nombreux en fin de
compte est donc je ne suis pas très
actif je fais pas partie du bureau mais
comme il y à des événements donc tout
proche d'ici donc
dans les yvelines donc je voulais être
au courant je voulais en faire partie
par contre presque aussi dans d'autres
groupes de travail quels sont les
groupes justement quelles sont les
thématiques les domaines qui aujourd'hui
en tant que député vous intéresse plus
particulièrement et sur lesquels vous
souhaitez apporter votre vos
connaissances
alors j'étais dans l'ain centre de
formation professionnelle donc dans les
yvelines avec plusieurs député des
yvelines et on travaille donc sur
l'apprentissage et ce qui est important
je travaille également beaucoup
actuellement sur le plan étudiants et
la réforme donc d'apb donc pour
l'orientation entre les lycées
professionnels et le monde étudiant
puisque je fais partie de la commission
des affaires culturelles et de
l'éducation
donc tout ce qui est éducation entre
l'éducation plus standard éducation
nationale et facultés ou bien
professionnel avec l'apprentissage sont
deux sujets qui me tiennent à coeur
je fais également en projet notamment
j'ai travaillé sur tout ce qui est
premiers secours et gestes qui sauvent
donc j'ai fait une opération pour former
des députés et tout au long du mandat
nous allons poursuivre et organiser
régulièrement des formations et on
organisera également dans ma
circonscription
j'ai travaillé jusque jusqu'à
la semaine dernière aussi sur
l'audiovisuel donc j'ai publié un
rapport donc c'est audiovisuels
notamment sur la réforme de la carte
vous avez l'impression que les choses
bougent ont évolué on sait quelques mois
de présidence d' emmanuel macron alors
les choses ont déjà beaucoup bougé mais
on essaye encore de les transformer donc
il ya des réformes en cours au sein de
l'assemblée nationale dont il ya des
groupes de travail donc justement pour
essayer de transformer nos méthodes de
travail parce que unique semble parfois
que les choses sont un petit peu
répétitive est en perte de temps
notamment il ya des projets de loi qu'on
voit en commission convoitant commission
qu'on revote d'un sommet national qui
portait ses mains qu'on revote une
deuxième donc on a parfois l'impression
de répéter trois fois de ma grossesse
donc on voudrait aller j'ai un petit peu
pour pouvoir aller plus vite un dernier
petit questionnaire rapide pour terminer
ce set cette émission ce café politique
si vous deviez retenir un film alors
j'ai longtemps dit merde c'est un très
vieux film j'avais beaucoup aimé le film
soleil de nuit avec le danseur
barychnikov parce que parce que j'ai
fait de la danse jeune que ça m'avait
beaucoup marqué plus récemment j'ai vu
le sens de la fête
voilà qui est aussi en train d'être très
bon film un livre un livre alors là en
ce moment je suis en train de livres
lire et je suis à la moitié de notre
hiller policier historique donc qui
écrit par quelqu'un la circonscription
que je connais bien qui est le secret de
sa manie et une musique pour terminer
ses chansons et musique j'aime beaucoup
melody gardot
merci beaucoup béatrice ferrant d'être
venu pour le café politique sur tv 78
merci beaucoup
[Musique]